MARIA: ALL THAT COMING UP BUT
FIRST, FLAGS ACROSS THE CAPITOL
ARE AT HALF STAFF THIS MORNING
IN REMEMBRANCE OF CIVIL RIGHTS
ICON, JOHN LEWIS.
THE LONG TIME GEORGIA
CONGRESSMAN PASSED AWAY FRIDAY
NIGHT AFTER A BATTLE WITH
PANCREATIC CANCER HE WAS 80
YEARS OLD.
LEWIS WAS THE LAST LIVING
SPEAKER AT THE 1963 MARCH ON
WASHINGTON WHERE DR. MARTIN
LUTHER KING JR. DELIVERED HIS "I
HAVE A DREAM" SPEECH.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
MCCARTHY WAS HIS FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE, HE JOINS ME NOW,
CONGRESSMAN IT IS GOOD TO SEE
YOU THIS MORNING.
MY CONDOLENCES.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU MARIA.
THANK YOU AND I DO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT JOHN LEWIS JUST FOR A
MOMENT BECAUSE HE LIVED SUCH AN
EXTRAORDINARY LIFE AND WAS AN
UNBELIEVABLE MAN.
AT SUCH A YOUNG AGE HE TRIED TO
CROSS A BRIDGE SIMPLY TO GIVE
PEOPLE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
HE DID IT IN A PEACEFUL MANNER
AND HE WAS BEATEN ALMOST TO HIS
DEATH.
I’VE WALKED ACROSS THAT BRIDGE
WITH HIM BEFORE, AND WHEN HE
WOULD TELL THE STORY HE WOULD
STOP AT A MOMENT AND SAYS I CAN
NOT REMEMBER BEYOND THIS POINT
BECAUSE THEY COULD BEAT HIM AND
HE DID IT IN A PEACEFUL MANNER
TO HELP CHANGE THIS NATION, THAT
NO LONGER PEOPLE KNEW CHOICE
ABOUT WHICH BATHROOM THEY USE OR
WHICH COUNTER THEY EAT ON OR
EVEN REGISTERING TO VOTE.
HE MADE THIS NATION BETTER AND
HE LIVED HIS LIFE IN A MANNER WE
COULD ALL RESPECT AND LIVE UP TO
AND HE WAS KIND TO ALL, AND I
JUST SPOKE TO HIM A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO, CHECKING ON HIS HEALTH BUT
TALKING TO HIM ABOUT WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN THE NATION TODAY
BECAUSE HE DID IT IN A PEACEFUL
MANNER TO HELP PRESERVE AND
ACTUALLY CREATE A MORE PERFECT
UNION.
I THINK A LOT TO UNDERSTAND HIM
AND LIVE BY HIS EXAMPLE, TO MAKE
THIS NATION BETTER.
MARIA: YES, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WHEN WE GO TO BREAK AFTER OUR
INTERVIEW WE’RE GOING TO SHOW A
LITTLE CLIP OF JOHN LEWIS WHICH
IS A BEAUTIFUL CLIP AND
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW THAT OUR
AUDIENCE WILL LOVE SO STAY WITH
US FOR THAT BUT LET ME GET TO
THE BUSINESS AT HAND FOR OUR
VIEWERS AND YOU’RE GOING BACK,
CONGRESS WILL RETURN TO WORK
TOMORROW AND YOU ARE LOOKING AT
A POTENTIAL NEXT STIMULUS
PACKAGE, A RELIEF PACKAGE.
WHAT SHOULD BE IN THAT PACKAGE,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> A NUMBER OF THINGS SHOULD BE
IN THAT PACKAGE BUT WE ALSO HAVE
A LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY, MORE
THAN ABOUT 1.5 TRILLION STILL
OUT THERE THAT WE’VE ALREADY
APPROPRIATED THAT WE NEED TO GET
INTO THIS ECONOMY, BUT THE
THINGS I LOOK FOR AND THE
THINGS WE NEED TO DO, WE
NEED LIABILITY OF PROTECTION,
BECAUSE THESE SMALL BUSINESSES
ARE QUESTIONING WHETHER THEY CAN
OPEN AGAIN.
OUR SCHOOLS AND OTHERS, SO LET’S
PROTECT THOSE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
LET’S ALSO LOOK AT ANYTIME
YOU’RE USING FEDERAL
MONEY IT SHOULDN’T GIVE YOU DE
INCENTIVIZE THE ABILITY TO
WORK.
WE’VE MADE A MISTAKE WHERE WE
OVERPAID ON UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE WHERE NOW IT’S HARD
FOR PEOPLE TO COME BACK TO WORK
BECAUSE THEY’RE MAKING MORE ON
UNEMPLOYMENT THAN THEY CAN
WORKING SO WE’VE GOT TO
STRAIGHTEN THAT OUT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
I WOULD LOOK AT PLACES THAT WE
SHOULD PRIORITIZE THE SAFETY
WHEN IT COMES TO CHILD CARE, OR
FOR OUR CHILDREN, OUR TEACHERS
INSIDE SCHOOLS, AND THEN I WOULD
LOOK AT THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
IF WE LEARN NOTHING FROM THIS ,
NOT THE LIES OF CHINA BUT
BRINGING THOSE JOBS BACK TO
AMERICA, BUT ALSO OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN ITSELF, NOT BEING BEHOLDEN
TO CHINA FOR SO MUCH OF
OUR CRITICAL MINERALS AND OTHERS
, LET’S FIND A WAY THAT WE
IMPROVE IT HERE AND FOR OUR
STOCKPILING I’D DO THAT IN A
DIFFERENT MANNER WORKING WITH
THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO STOPPILE
IT.
MARIA: SO THE PRESIDENT WOULD
LIKE SCHOOLS TO OPEN IN THE FALL
, CONGRESSMAN.
WILL THERE BE MONEY IN THIS NEXT
BILL FOR SCHOOLS AND WHAT ABOUT
THE STATES?
ARE THESE THE PRIORITIES RIGHT
NOW FOR THAT NEXT BILL?
>> WELL THE UNIQUENESS OF WHAT
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW, MARIA, WE
HAVE MORE THAN $100 BILLION THAT
WE’VE ALREADY APPROPRIATED THAT
CAN GO TO THE STATES.
I THINK WE CAN LOOK AT WAYS THAT
WE CAN MAKE THAT GREATER
FLEXIBILITY AND LOTS OF TIMES
WE’RE FINDING WHEN WE SENT THESE
MONEYS TO THESE GOVERNORS THAT
THEY’VE HELD IT UP INSTEAD OF
PUSHING IT DOWN TO THE COUNTIES
AND THE CITIES.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
FLEXIBILITY WHERE IT GOES TO THE
COUNTIES AND CITIES IN THE PLACE
OF NEED.
WE WOULD LOOK AT HOSPITALS THAT
THEY NEED MORE IN THE PROCESS OF
WHERE WE’RE GOING FORWARD.
WE ALSO HAVE MORE THAN
$100 BILLION SITTING THERE FOR
SUCH A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM OF PPP
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES,
THAT SAVED MILLIONS OF JOBS.
NOW WE’RE SEEING THAT SOME
STATES HAVE TO CLOSE CERTAIN
PORTIONS.
IS THERE A GREATER NEED FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES?
WE ALREADY HAVE MONEY SITTING
THERE, SO COULD WE USE THE MONEY
ALREADY APPROPRIATED TO SOLVE
SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS?
MARIA: SURE, I UNDERSTAND, BUT
YOU KNOW, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
PUSHING BACK ON THE PRESIDENT
SAYING HE WANTS TO OPEN SCHOOLS,
AND I WONDER HOW MUCH OF THIS IS
POLITICS, ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW, IT
IS SCARY FOR PARENTS TO SAY
WE’RE GOING TO SEND OUR KIDS
BACK-TO-SCHOOL AND WE DON’T KNOW
WHAT THE SITUATION IS IN TERMS
OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
WE’RE SEEING SPIKES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND HERE IS WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOLD ME JUST
RECENTLY WHEN I INTERVIEWED HIM
AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PANDEMIC.
LISTEN TO THIS.
YOUR CRITICS WANT YOU TO KEEP IT
CLOSED GOING INTO THE ELECTION?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: YEAH, I DO, I
DO.
I THINK IT’S A POLITICAL THING.
MARIA: THEY’RE SAYING YOU’RE
PUTTING MONEY, BUSINESS, AHEAD
OF LIVES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: NO, NO.
I THINK THE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
SEE THE RIGHT THING HAPPEN, THEY
AGREE WITH ME.
THEY HAVE TO GET OUR COUNTRY
OPEN.
YOU KNOW IF IT WAS UP TO SOME
PEOPLE LET’S KEEP IT CLOSED FOR
A LONG TIME, OKAY?
A LONG TIME AND WATCH THE UNITED
STATES GO DOWN THE TUBES.
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
MARIA: I MEAN, I GUESS WE ARE
GOING TO BE LIVING WITH THIS ,
CONGRESSMAN BUT CAN WE ACTUALLY
GO BACK TO OUR NORMAL LIVES
SAFELY RIGHT NOW GIVEN THESE
SPIKES THAT WE’RE SEEING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY?
>> IN CERTAIN PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY YOU CAN.
NOBODY WANTS TO SEND SOMEBODY TO
SCHOOL THAT’S UNSAFE.
THAT’S WHY CONGRESS SHOULD
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THIS.
HOW CAN WE PROTECT WHEN IT COMES
TO CHILD CARE, THE CHILDREN IN
SCHOOL AND THE TEACHERS BUT
WHAT’S MORE IMPORTANT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THESE RECENT STUDIES
YOU’RE FINDING THAT CHILDREN
SHOULD NOT, HAVE NOT KEPT THEIR
READING, THEIR WRITING AND THEIR
MATH, LOSING MORE THAN 30% OF IT
WE CANNOT HAVE A WHOLE
GENERATION THAT’S UNEDUCATED.
SO WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
ACTUALLY PUT THAT PLAN TOGETHER,
BECAUSE WE’VE GOT TO MAKE SURE,
SCHOOLS CAN REOPEN, AND THAT
TAKES A RESPONSIBILITY OF WHAT
WE’RE DOING AND NOW WE’RE
FINDING EVEN IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
LA AND SAN DIEGO SAY
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO OPEN FOR
THE WHOLE YEAR?
REMEMBER WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE
WITH WARP SPEED.
WE’VE GOT FIVE COMPANIES THAT
ARE IN BARTER THAT HAVE A REAL
PROMISE OF HAVING A VACCINE,
COULD EVEN BE THIS YEAR.
OR  THE THERAPIES COMING FORWARD
TOMORROW IS GOING TO BE BETTER
THAN TODAY BASED UPON WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
YES?
MARIA: LOOK WHAT’S HAPPENING TO
OUR CITIES I KNOW YOU HAVE A
BILL RIGHT NOW TO PUNISH ANYBODY
WHO IS TAKING DOWN STATUES, BUT
THERE’S A MASSIVE MOVEMENT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE, YOUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE LEFT THEY WANT
TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
LISTEN TO JOE BIDEN RECENTLY.
HERE IT IS.
>> WE AGREE THAT WE CAN
REDIRECT SOME OF THE FUNDING?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE ALSO
NEED TO BE DOING IS FUNDAMENTAL
LY CHANGING THE WAY
AND I’VE BEEN PUSHING IT FOR
YEARS, CHANGING THE WAY WE
DEAL WITH OUR PRISON SYSTEM.
IT SHOULD BE A REHABILITATION
SYSTEM, NOT A PUNISHMENT SYSTEM.
MARIA: WELL WHAT DOES THAT MEAN,
CONGRESSMAN?
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING THIS BAIL
REFORM IN NEW YORK ALLOW
CRIMINALS BACK ON THE STREET AND
THAT’S ONE OF THE REASONS CRIME
IS SKYROCKETING.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSIBILITY AS
THE LEADER OF THE GOP TO GET
LAW AND ORDER BACK IN PLACE
IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> WELL EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD
BE SCARED RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WHAT
YOU JUST SHOWED COUNTRY WAS JOE
BIDEN SAID YES, HE IS FOR DE
FUNDING THE POLICE.
YOU’VE GOT
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR WHO WANTS TO
DISMANTLE AMERICA AND THEN
YOU’VE GOT NANCY PELOSI WHOSE
ALLOWING THEM TO DESTROY AMERICA
FROM STATUES AND ON.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY FOR
RULE AND LAW AND FOR JUSTICE
, AND WHAT WE’RE
WATCHING THE DEMOCRATS DOING,
WATCH WHAT NANCY PELOSI JUST
SAID THE OTHER DAY.
SHE THINKS WHAT’S HAPPENING IS
IN PORTLAND IS A GRAFFITI
PROBLEM.
NO IT’S A MOB PROBLEM THAT IS
OVERRUNNING.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE ACROSS THIS
NATION SCARED TO DEATH.
YOU HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN BEING
MURDERED, BECAUSE WHAT THEY’RE
DOING TO THE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THIS IS WRONG.
MARIA: SO YOUR BILL DOES WHAT?
>> OUR BILL WILL WITHHOLD
FEDERAL GRANTS FOR CITIES THAT
DO NOT UPHOLD AND PROTECT THE
STATUES, BECAUSE THE CITIES
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR LAW
AND ORDER, NOT TO LEAVE THESE
PRECINCTS, NOT TO ALLOW THESE
MOBS TO RULE OUR COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE TO STAND UP TO THIS.
MARIA: IT IS SCARY OUT THERE I
AGREE WITH YOU CONGRESSMAN IT’S
GOOD TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING WE
CERTAINLY WILL BE WATCHING THE